[Music]
president tweeted quote the dams were
trying to distance themselves from the
four progresses but now they're forced
to embrace them and that means they are
endorsing socialism hate of Israel and
the USA not good for Democrats also
breaking tonight White House counselor
to the president Kellyanne Conway to
fight a congressional subpoena with full
support of the White House let me read
from pets abalone the White House
Counsel that he sent to congressman
Elijah Cummings in accordance with
long-standing bipartisan precedent miss
Conway cannot be compelled to testify
before Congress with respect to matters
related to our service as a senior
advisor to the president the Department
of Justice has advised me that Miss
Conway's absolute absolutely immune from
compelled congressional testimony with
respect to matters related to her
service as a senior advisor to the
president which by the way is exactly
right Kelly and Conway joins us now I
don't think you look too worried that's
what I have known you for many years
you've been on the show many years you
don't look particularly concerned I'm
concerned that there's such a
politicization and weaponization of this
thing called the Hatch Act if you go
back and look at some of the things that
are in the original report
they're just ripped from the headlines
they're not my opinion so here's an
example that they put in their report
originally that I said that the
Democratic frontrunners are two old
white male career politicians so at the
time it was Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
ahead in the polls I'm just reading the
newspaper here Sean ahead in the polls
now at fact-check they're white they're
old they're male and they're going to
tell you what you're guilty of you'll
like the president you'll like the
president this is the treatment anybody
goes so effective I'm also effective in
treating his policies to American
everybody knew is that that's a good
point thanks so much thanks so much for
the flattery that somehow a TV
appearance by me in the spring of 2019
can swing an election in 2020 but
they're just nice well they know that I
helped the president who got elected all
by himself but I
and I'm still here talking about his
policies they would have liked me to
have been I think hauled in front of the
Office of Special Counsel mr. Muller but
they couldn't do that because I ran a
campaign they didn't speak to Russians I
would didn't talk to anybody in Moscow I
talk to people in Michigan let me ask
you a real question North Carolina but
but this is a serious matter in that I
would like to testify I have nothing to
hide I've done nothing wrong and but
there is a long-standing bipartisan
precedent and it applies to
administration's of both parties and
what would really happen if the Hatch
Act were applied retroactively Lee to
other people's members of their
administration have you seen some of the
things they've said and done that never
got this kind of treatment I would also
just tell your viewers to look at the
letter sent by White House Counsel pass
the Bologna dated June 11th his original
response it is brilliant and everybody
should pull up that letter because in it
he says and this has never been
contested by the guy who went under
earth probably thought it was a good
idea to testify he'd be fun but oh how
difficult it actually is especially
we're not telling the truth the entire
time more about that some other time but
what passive learn he said was that what
this this special counsel the office
special counsel which has a 25 million
plus dollar budget and it's supposed to
be an independent agency that he felt
pressure from members of the press that
he is capitulating to people on Capitol
Hill we want them to quote do something
about Kellyanne they're not going to
silence me they're not going to take
away my First Amendment rights I'm
immune from testifying what do you make
of the president's tweet the Devens are
trying to distance themselves from the
real leaders of the Democratic Party and
forced to embrace them and you know look
at omar's comments about Israel and the
u.s. and endorsing socialism and the
green new deal etc all about the
Benjamins yes laughing about Arcadia and
lying today in the press conference I
mean I'm always amazed when the fact
checkers just go gaga and genuflect when
any one of the squad the squad who apart
from getting a lot of media attention
haven't done squat
they don't fact-check these people but
look the president's right all last week
Pelosi looks like Meeks the
Congressional Black Caucus were all
raining down
these women for attacking that they're
the only four Democrats to vote against
any humanitarian aid crisis on the
border they have no moral authority to
talk about the border anymore they voted
against 4.6 billion dollars in aid
Pelosi speaker in name only
kelly-ann good to see it thank you for
being with us